non ci posso credere che siamo veramente
arrivati a questo momento è da tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovi dio
sono fa vj ed oggi siamo sullo speciale
mille video
porcaccia va a mille video è una magia
che manco sto cristiano riesce a facendo
per capire voi dite ci sono un sacco di
youtube hanno fatto molto più di mille
vide lo so che non c'entra un cazzo
questa se io so quanto lavoro c'è dietro
uno dei miei video o meno un anno esatto
fa avevo fatto una specie di reaction ai
miei video vecchi quindi questa volta
cercherò di farla analizzando un po
meglio che cosa era fa vj che non chi
era che che cosa questo non era questa
non è la persona questa è una cosa che
cazzo ciò in testa santo iddio sarà una
cosa difficile però let's rock allora
che a soli per la prima volta volevo
ripartire guardando il mio primo video
ma primo perché il primo di parigi tv è
questo che lo slider ritorna che bel
santo di dio benedetto in realtà questo
non è il mio primo video il mio primo
vero video da youtube air l'ho fatto sul
the shard gaming che è stato il mio
primo canale che attualmente è il canale
di nichi box auto ve lo lasciamo in
descrizione è il primo vero video che ho
fatto risale a cinque anni fa
tra l'altro chat più o meno è sempre lui
gli ho fatto a luglio caso successo è
tra l'altro da quasi cinque anni di fila
che faccio youtuber ragazzo scoperto
adesso sentite come pronuncio questa
frase monologo fastidio quali j siamo
due ragazzi di 16 anni e due non mi
stavo vantando di avere 16 anni c'erano
due ragazzi di 16 anni e facciamo i
video abbiamo appena iniziato abbia
appena dato questo canale di share e il
gaming appunto perché vogliamo perché
vogliamo pausa non sapevo che cazzo dire
la verità non c'è un cazzo da fare lei
aperto non c'è un cazzo da fare recare a
luglio mi annoiavo essendo due giocatori
abbastanza esperti di fps i giochi di
guerra ma che cazzo dici che gameplay
non è manco tu roma santo gesù cody che
dobbiamo parlare del single player o
multiplayer
finalmente una bella descrizione del
gioco sentiamo che cosa ha da dirci il
nostro fa vj single player o multiplayer
nile iniziare un poco single player che
la parte più cioè la principale che
usciranno i commenti che sono singoli
del multi dicendo penso ragazzi che
tutti quanti abbiate presente skyrim
io ero un fan accanito proprio tanto
gli oblivion che era il capitolo prima
di skyrim quando uscì il trailer di
skyrim ci feci subito un commento di
sopra e questo il video prestate
attenzione a come pronuncio la parola
skyrim
vi prego è pronta questa volta il
gameplay e commentati che abbiamo fatto
e di dischi rim come avevamo e di cosa
dischi non ho capito di scream
non è che me lo ripeti un'altra volta di
chi perfetto e quello che mi sono
giustificato con l'annotazione si si lo
so si pronuncia skyrim non skirring
tutti sbagliano xd se cerchi non si può
sentire lo so lo so ragazzi non si sente
per niente che sto facendo questo
commentari alle 2 di notte per non
svegliare i miei genitori parlo così
facevano anche mettere i dischi perché
lo portavamo quantità non va bene va
bene e invece ragazzi questa è stata la
prima volta che mi sono fatto vedere in
faccia in un video tra l'altro 22 luglio
2011 casa di fa vj questa new york non
si capisce proprio che hai preso le
immagini del cazzo hai messaggio va beh
eccoci e bay e quel bellissimo uomo che
sta ridendo sotto i baffi cercando di
non farsi notare ma tanto si vede
benissimo si chiama fa vj e quella roba
che c'è in testa dovrebbe avere un nome
proprio ma cerchiamo di capire qual è il
nome giusto da scegliere per il canale
per la mia mente le grane abita scuse io
toby perché praticamente quando lo
seguivo un sacchetto anche adesso lo
seguo però un tempo e molto di più e gli
avevo scritto sotto un video tipo sei
ingrassato a caso e lui aveva risposto
bellissimo the shelf gaming che mi dice
sei ingrassato ma perché spero che tu
sia contento beh più o meno bella a
tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo blog non si nota per niente la
felpa di baci e abbracci santo gesù
benedetto tra quelli che mi avete
consigliato allora happy wheels me
l'avete consigliato in tantissimi
farò qualche episodio penso proprio di
sì per il giusto fatto due o tre episodi
di è più severa non ti credere gli
avevano infatti così tanti poi ma
lorenzo lavoravi alla coop
no perché minchia favi questo vissuto i
capelli sono illegali di miei capelli no
perché non hai visto la felpa frate mi
fate vedere un atto eccolo questo qua
fantasma ciò che allegria guarda guarda
guarda ma che cazzo mi diceva il
cervello non c'è niente non c'è niente
che poi ragazzi in realtà ai tempi
c'erano veramente pochissimi giochi
horror di questo era la massima qualità
di videogioco horror che esisteva ai
tempi vorrebbe che figo ragazzi il primo
episodio di è quindi a tutti i ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video io sono
dio e oggi siamo nel primissimo episodio
di harry wales
sì però stai calmo e questo invece
ragazzi è stato uno dei miei primi vlog
in assoluto 31 agosto 2013 che poi trato
curiosità il telecomando è rimasto
sempre lo stesso in questi tre fottuti
anni non ho mai cambiato telecomando ed
è un miracolo e considerando quante
volte mi è caduto il detto conto che i
miei capelli ai tempi guardate bene come
sono fatti i c print e sono piatti poi
una volta che arrivano alle sopracciglia
fanno la curva ci hanno con una un'onda
non so se d'estate nuotando tra l'altro
una delle cose più curiose che quella
maglia che vedete nel video quella blu
con scritta fa vj e poi la stessa
identica maglia che indosso anche adesso
perché io nel tempo ho sempre e solo
usato esclusivamente queste maglie qua
c'è probabilmente sono sempre state
queste sono le uniche quattro maglie che
utilizzato da quando ho aperto il canale
e sono speciali soprattutto per il fatto
che non lo lavate neanche una volta
quindi vengono proprio il sudore di ogni
singolo video benissimo devo trovare
qualcosa da non ci vede bene reca a
trovarmi su creato per adesso si giochi
di merda mi devono mai visto più facendo
affanculo e con il tempo ragazzi o
migliorate mia gameplay facendo giochi
sempre un po più di qualità e la
gestiamo su barbie
[Musica]
g
cosa sto facendo della mia vita
guarda me lo sto chiedendo ancora adesso
zio e invece quei ragazzi che hanno
mandato il golden button per il milione
di iscritti che praticamente il mio
golden button è proprio il primo della
serie quella che faceva youtube dove
metteva anche i loghi del canale adesso
non li mettono più si va non solo il
nome del canale
quindi il mio golden button al cazzo più
lungo sul plot che tra l'altro siamo
arrivati veramente a 2 milioni e 900
mila iscritti ragazzi youtube da temere
tre di questi cosi maledetti tirchi e
quindi ragazzi siamo oggi arrivati qui
alla bellezza di mille video fatti vi
rendete conto che siamo arrivati a 2
milioni 911 mila 492 iscritti e tutto
questo nel giro di tre anni e quel
bastardo di merda credere gazzoli spero
che vi sia piaciuto cosa sia piaciuto
sull'argomento è un mi piace anche a
pagina di facebook è come il vino
tornare descrizione grazie ragazzi che
mi avete portato su di due iscritti se
ne saresti discreti rifiutiamo prossimo
video mi e vi chiedete come fa a non
essersi ancora rotto me lo chiedo
anch'io
va bene da ragazzi